it has been so long my beard grew
backwards and my nose broke again
[Laughter]
grew back backwards what is that what is
that I I I'm clean shaven at the moment
and my nose is broken
I thought you were a human being
you don't need to hurt my feelings this
early we have plenty of time to hurt my
feelings I'm recording already it's okay
yeah yeah well me too it's content it's
content content so long as this content
I guess it makes it all okay man these
animals are depressed well they built
this boat for months so we've neglected
yeah they're gonna be fine uh Hey guys
welcome to Raft part one who doesn't
have intros
dolphin who does intros intros are for
nerds
opponents right Mark uh yeah right buddy
oh yeah
the battery's empty on the nav computer
hey everybody Welcome to seven scary
horror games part 62.
wow I'm up to part 98 now you're really
behind you man I gotta catch up I have a
good friend I'm sorry
um so were we like I forget how lexian
ended my last one were we dying to
Typhoon the Kraken uh uh
what are we doing well I think clearly
nothing because we're here
Sharknado right that's what it was this
time we can die to squid NATO what what
NATO oh that's not right yeah squid NATO
it's
I thought you're being for real okay
we're headed to tangaroa I think is the
newer one yeah kangaroo
uh-huh is that a Pixar movie sure is
angeroa barely knewer right Wade you're
ready
I have to agree because you said right
Wade I feel like that's a dangerous
precedent that I'm gonna immediately
cancel
no no keep it up the whole time it'll be
crazy call backs oh I couldn't possibly
right Mark uh yep all right uh we need
to go do
in 90 degrees Due West we need to turn
west a full 90 degrees I think it's the
we're going to the one that it has a box
around that's like a Target right
yeah so we'll turn
turning oh you gotta go up to your
Captain's
hey it's not it's it's more of a
captain's Studio
[Music]
ah too far you overshot it you gotta get
it I need more warning than stop
stop yeah perfect you nailed it yeah
actually got it yeah that's perfect okay
okay turning off navigation because we
don't need that anymore
we're going the right way come on yeah
of course of course we is oh right we
need protators
we need honey
I got a potato where do you put on the
potato for arcs no no I need a lot of
potato not your piddly baby potato here
here's lots of okay I don't even want to
touch your potato there's so many
potatoes there potato is pathetic touch
my potatoes I will not I will never work
your voice got this deeper
potato oh yeah that's weird that's the
way down
Bob shut up no one wants to talk to your
Guru oh okay I don't know why we
switched trolls yeah and switch trolls
this you guys I guess we could just talk
like ourselves the internet can't tell
us apart maybe Mark can't that's kind of
the joke I was going for but more subtly
you know with less declaring it yeah
stuff that's the joke he was making is
it funny now audience let him know in
the comments
definitely funny we're we are in this
good to know where our comedy is as
tight as ever is there a water thing all
the way up here to Phil because I once
upon a time the trees or whatever the
potatoes yeah until someone probably
took them all they just ate them did you
eat all the potatoes that were in there
who are you asking Wade no I don't eat
potatoes I don't do that I bet he did
here's a potato
there's four potatoes down here by the
cooking stuff
all right I guess I'll scrounge up
without no scratch Mark okay all right
what happened to all the potatoes I want
to point out that this is the third
floor and it takes effort to get up here
and effort's one thing we here at wage
don't do I asked you to do that
what to fill the water thing well no I'm
saying I wouldn't have taken the
potatoes because they're all the way up
here did you take the potatoes no I'm
not taking any potatoes you just
admitted he took the potatoes yeah it
doesn't sound like that doesn't it yeah
you should check the potatoes
yes I do agree it's Irish accent hour I
remember back when we started this how
we had the wheel of Captain that was fun
way back way remember that
no I don't know yeah no one they were
awful because they're idiots although
this is a nice Captain's nest
it's a studio apartment I hear shark
eating somewhere somewhere what happened
dark eating somewhere oh you're a [__]
eating wow there's a boat over there
should I get it
yes absolutely you're getting off and go
get it right now I'm getting it
I'm sorry extra Motors
uh we have actually we have Motors yeah
start on the extra motor speed we gotta
get out of here coming back oh okay oh
hey hey welcome back
you can't escape him with my flippers
you have flippers I got flippers this
man wasting plastic oh what no it's so
dark up here I want light
someone put a big burning ball of light
in the sky what's that robot mark
robot Mark row Scooby no no no
what's that sound that's like a shark
eating something uh no
oh okay good
I'm glad I don't have to worry about
that shark sound look I didn't like that
part of the boat anyway don't matter oh
hey Mark welcome back
hello we might need another
just gonna make a bunch of these into
rooms wait don't
are you making a chest because I'm no I
was gonna convert a bunch of the Palm
leaves into rope because rope takes up
less space totally unable to close my
crafting menu yeah I'm lagging wait is
your internet okay
I think so I'm stuck in a menu right now
well as we record this not the date the
episode but there is a murderous cloud
of death over my state so it's possible
I'm about to explode
well I'm sorry what does that date the
episode two all the time all right this
is Ohio not California
oh
got him
no no who told them about the cloud of
death in California
that was our secret
oh god wow I am so boned right now my
dudes what what's up I fell off the boat
raft okay you're on the boat
I got back I can't I can't turn because
my mouse is stuck in menu mode we like
leave and rejoin I don't know I don't
know I don't think it's lag I think
you're just broken
uh I'm all to afford my way out of this
well hold on Mark is teleporting around
no I'm fine I'm great are you are you
like thinking something on your computer
or something what's happening man I'm no
there's literally not even a question I
trusted you
yeah wait I think this is your fault
oh no ass faces joined the raft hey
there's a big island ahead of us to the
left no that's hungry that's not a big
island there's a big-ish island ahead of
us to the left it's tiny itty-bitty all
right have you ever been shaving these
animals do we need to shave them do we
have a shaveable animal uh yes
okay
I hope that answered your question
oh yeah thoroughly I'm lagging again oh
man I am lagging hard do you sound
better well I think it's your internet
Wade
um no not so fun now when it's you
I'm pretty sure the answer is uh
yeah
listen guys I gotta be honest I forget
what this sign said on it so I'm just
gonna put a blank sign there oh we had
fish farming craft and junk
and oh
yeah
we're 570 meters away from the the thing
Place cap Captain Captain you're the
captain
's 570 meters away from the place me
self I don't know if anyone's hey we
skipped the island we didn't need that
Island we don't need that garbage didn't
you hear us talking guys don't go too
far without me
what do you mean I killed the shark so I
jumped off to get the meat oh
get off he's attacking the boat no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
Mark he killed me I'm sorry
am I sorry am I am I no I actually no
I'm not sorry
bark you had me at hell no guys I see a
big dome ahead
yeah it's your forehead
[Music]
that was really hurtful I feel like you
know
who's hurtful forehead yeah Wade
apologize
oh ass face
yes please okay
good to know I'm stuck in the menu I'm
stuck in the menu
I'm good I'm good no I got out of it
with my skill hey some of your potatoes
are getting eaten by a scarecrow and I'm
not gonna help you you're eaten by
the thing that the scarecrows are
related to scare birds life
Birdman uh right gotcha shut up I hate
you I wasn't even talking our teamwork
is phenomenal we'll start this day hey a
dome
wow it's almost as big as Bob you should
apologize forehead
damn wow
oh man you know
forehead is two cheeks and a crack just
like anyone else
I'm sorry what because he's got kind of
an ass face
uh
I can't interact with anything what is
happening can't touch anything like
someone has bad internet whoa
did you hear that no I heard the the
Nets gathered everything in one big
all right
now it's a party I can't touch them
oh we're moving oh guy I ate something
that seems like your responsibility to
maintain what you're eating I guess I I
mean it was kind of like not my choice
in a way oh
just ate something
um oh these planted ah I see what
happened and trees are a stupid
investment
they really are I don't even means trees
I don't know why did I wish would you
rather grow something else I
see this is the side you've chosen Mark
I just want to say I didn't choose that
side yo chose yeah
but he is one you chose correctly this
is how I oh hey do we care about the
Dome that we're leaving we're not
leaving it we're navigating to the
entrance oh maybe do it better you see
the big arrows on the wall
um no not for my current wait do you
even know how to pile of this boat you
can't imagine the skill it probably
takes no I don't know how to apply it I
spent so much time doing everything that
doesn't involve sitting in a chair and
turning the wheel
that I don't know how to do the easy
part this guy thinks he's just sitting
in a chair turning a wheel
that's good on the wheel and then go to
the couch with a hot tub yeah all right
we're here
whoo what do we do
go in I guess I don't know
I'm just a wheel turner not for me to
know you're just a chair-sitting wheel
turner uh remember to dump your
inventories before you go in there uh
get ready for combat
hey guy who's dominating the chest that
has all of the wood in existence hey
what do you want it's my chest now
thanks you're welcome
and we have a blueprint for a battery
charger
research titanium Fort I think oh right
foreign
I don't know what I remember
oh wait wait say that again what did you
ask about the what of limitations
statute okay now the statue of
limitations just checking just checking
I just watched Mark drink all this water
and not refill because my water bottle
is not empty I was packing for the trip
you monster I'm going in I can't take it
anymore
how do I get in I'm in there's a big
Arrow hole door I'm situation I'm in is
that a Game of Thrones thing are there
is this dangerous
why is it scary in here
because life is scary what do you want
that's true but there doesn't seem to be
life in here either
what do you mean I'm right behind you
no you're not oh
look out for this one
oh that's right I need like my Spears
almost which way you gonna go
left all right that's why I'm calling
you
correctly see you later good luck
you can fight the Rabid Beaver monster
I'm not gonna do it
oh they have good meat oh God it's a
dead end
oh Beaver monster I'm gonna kill it oh
it jumps I should have brought my bows
and arrows that would have been really
smart
meat thank you why did you have bows and
arrows and not bring bows and arrows oh
man connection cause he's a fool Jim
Snow
what Savage
got him just take the L Mark take the L
all right okay
sure take it to the bank and cash it
with these nuts
got me again uh Mark there's an evil
Beaver coming behind you nah
I can't I won't believe your lies who's
talking in my head I'm trying to outrun
the fleet of rafts or something
it's going to overheat the reactor
I sent the message up the tower
totally doesn't care
I hope you're faring bethorama
much better oh no that's a freaking
the door is locked from the other side I
found a generator part I'm a hero rat
beaver
wow you were pathetic rat
wait a way to waste your one opportunity
it's sweet sweet food how many generator
pieces do we need I don't know I just
found one look at Jillian a Jillian damn
I don't have anywhere near a Julian it's
dark this is like X-Files Anderson
anything
hey Marcus Eve I can't see anything are
you guys in the cafeteria
uh yeah we're working our way toward
the crane he's right we are not in the
cafeteria he said yes I'm right behind
Mark we're not we are heading there
right now there's no we are not in the
rat beavers that no one took the time to
kill that's cool they're just oh man to
be fair I killed the ones I encountered
for a myth well minus the one I left to
kill Mark I left Mark to kill I mean
Wade
I feel like this is a task suited to
your incredible Intel all right you
solve it I'll be down there all right
I'll be down there you solve it
great great waiting for you waiting for
you on your go uh Bob we found something
for you
I'll do it what are we doing if you
would tell me where you are I would
literally you do what you do on the boat
you stand and press buttons well I'm
excellent I just came through the
cafeteria uh mine bars
where are you uh oh you went wrong way
ah [__] you don't know
when you see a terrifying creature
standing in front of you it's me oh
hello hello your flippers look stupid
I'm just gonna say that now
Hey where's my job uh it's up in the
ladder to the right yeah okay don't
worry I'll be in the thing so uh don't
cause any horrible industrial accidents
where I get wedged in between two of
these crap and help Bob just in case he
causes horrible industrial accidents all
right I'm waiting for it
where are you Mark far left I'm right
here red lit box well I'm not in the red
list uh this isn't doing anything
are we still missing
maybe we need to do the job no you just
moved it you just moved to the crane
just moved something what you moved it I
heard it it went
it's not moving on my screen so I don't
see it moving now whoa you moved just
moved it uh wait I think you actually
need to do that
I've not pressed anything oh it says
that you need to evacuate Personnel from
the crane area oh
get out of there dummy you dummy
sorry
I'm sorry oh hey it's moving now that's
crazy oh cool I can crawl under that no
I can't drop it on him
why is that
the maximum amount of you got lifted
higher oh I would if I if and I could no
you can only move it left or right you
can't lift it higher
so see how it's
surrounded
ah
yeah all right
yeah I don't think I'm done yet oh okay
can you go can you can you go I'm in the
third level in but I can't go under that
or anything
interesting I'm not good at this sort of
thing guys I gotta be honest
wait you're up
move the move move the do maybe move the
green one yeah
yeah
then we got a then we got a it's a
little clog now let me check no look hey
wow look at you mark
you you made it to there
I'm doing it guys yeah Bob if you see
while he's in there oh you're down there
yeah as soon as he runs in there the top
monitor says Eric I know so uh that's
what I was saying yeah I'm just telling
you that what you already know guys I'm
on a secret mission uh
my mission from got
damn it there's gotta be a way to just
break sequence break this and just climb
up on top probably can you stand on my
head
get on my head can you go into the
corner here and try and get up on the
ladder I can try yeah oh oh
yes now Crouch
let me on Daddy
oh
where'd you go wait where are you oh
there's a ladder there's a ladder there
how did you get up there
is it oh there's a ladder on the wall oh
but no that's that I can't reach that
you're up don't come down you're doing
great look I'm across from you Wade look
yeah I see you now you disappeared when
you went further left all right now now
uh pull me up
yep pull me up
grab grab my
beer grab the spear give me the longest
part of your Anatomy
that's good that is sturdy uh it's not
working wait you guys solved yet I can't
move it while he's up there no there's
an internal path through wait can you
not can you not move it while I no you
count as being in there when you're okay
right now I can I think if we could find
a way to get mark up here we could
really be on to something I got I gotta
be honest can you not be there wait give
me a boost wait give me a boost yeah
wait wait
this is important we're playing the game
as it's meant to be played right here
Crouch down I see
so close jump for me
thank you all right all right how do we
use this
thing that the developer clearly let us
figure on purpose where can you go
wedge me Daddy I'm wedging wedge I'm
wedged
edge wedge mate we're wedged
man it's pretty tight fit here wait wait
yeah wait wait wait
Crouch crouching crouch for a second
scratching
now stand up standing
and now I'm gonna jump yeah watch me
wedging you wedge wedging or wedging ah
you won wedge let me crowd ah there must
be a way to clip there must be a way to
clip this how do you clip things in
video games uh let's get a speedrunner
on the horn wait
what do you want if we have three people
here you saw me play speed Runners I
made you laugh really hard because I was
so bad at it I know you were excellent
at it maybe if we clip through here
on me
yeah all right now stand up I can't
stand up whoops I got four stats hold it
oh it's not even letting me jump so we
must be close
come on we're getting there look into my
eyes while we do it I am looking I'm
well you do have this weird bore head so
I'm looking at your snout look into my
snoot I'm looking in here look up my
snoot I am can't do anything else really
yep yep
hang on watch while I eat this soup okay
look at look into my soup
it looked like you just birthed that
watermelon
yeah you like watermelon too right
yeah oh just very gently and then uh-huh
we're getting there I feel like we're
making progress we're making progress
we're making progress wait are you
solving your stupid puzzle or whatever
I'm working on it
hey wait where did Wayne go coming
Closer by the hour hey wait a minute I'm
sealing up the reactor all right guys
you've almost got it keep going wait a
minute
don't go in it's not safe
we did it I believe you guys did that
I call that Mouse hurdling see that
pretty good
oh there's The Gutter Guys I might have
done a bad
why can't I climb the water ladder oh
guys
um guys problem
probably Mark I'm running to the bowels
oh God
oh God maybe we should shut off this
water
how
don't worry um
just just start breathing it wait this
is the cafeteria I don't think this is
where we're supposed to be
um
oh God
oh boy
friends
better we can climb up the water ladder
because the water floats that's up it
don't wait
don't tell him
don't tell me what don't listen Wade
okay
um
yeah I think this might just end with me
drowning no
I can't I
as I found a way to get air but I also
found a way to not climb I can't climb
the ladder uh really
yeah well I'm I'm up-ish
did you go up the Leaky ladder no yeah
but also I went backwards and I almost
made it back to the ship which is not
what we want oh wait we've done it uh
you did you used me and got up I'm up
here now how is it up there it's a tiny
room look take my hand
I feel like I'm grabbing you by the dick
but I'm trying
yeah no this uh this is not uh
excellent this isn't where we were
screaming upstairs
it feels like someone might have
progressed broke out no supported
Tully's orders
really did not
oh
boy isn't saying much
kangaroo is a lost cause
we're getting out of here
where are you guys are you guys okay
here we go through the cafeteria Mark is
that where you went no I went up the you
remember the broken ladder the above the
thing in the thing
no you know where we were hopscotching
to
to no end
you go up that you because the water
level Rose and you can
you can do it now
I don't think this is break the room I
don't think this is it wait I gotta be
honest oh there's a bunch of stuff here
though
all you buddy
oh you do you guys need help or
um
[Music]
hey I got some good news we got bananas
yeah he's fine okay
ignore him he's fine
I usually do but this seemed concerning
it was a little
bit all right have you found the fields
of electrical conduction
security team still going no oh hey
what's up hey how's it going Bob do you
guys need me to come back for you
it's so interesting that that door just
opened on its own now
yeah
I feel like I was there before look I
was right there there's no engine the
rough kid thinks we could take one of
the golf cart engines
it's not a bad idea
Captain Tully and the investors Electric
juice Tower yeah okay there you go
[Music]
wow
guys you gotta see this
[Music]